how unlikely do you think
life is on earth so when you look
when you study other planets and you
study the contents of other planets
does that give you a perspective on um
the origin of life on earth
which again is full of mystery in itself
not the evolution but the origin
the first springing to life like from
from nothing to life from the basic
ingredients to life
and i guess another way of asking is how
unique are we
yeah it's a great question and it's one
that
just scientifically we don't have an
answer to
we don't even know how many times life
evolved on earth if it was only once or
if it happened independently a thousand
times in different places
we don't know whether it's happened
anywhere else
in the universe although it feels absurd
to believe
that we are the only life that evolved
in the entire universe but it's
conceivable we just have
just no real information we don't
understand really how life came about in
the first place on earth i mean
so if you look at the drake equation
that tries to estimate how many alien
civilizations are out there
planets have a big part to play in that
equation
if you were to bet money uh
in terms of the odds of uh origins of
life on earth
i mean this all has to do with how
special and unique is earth
what you land in terms of the number of
civilizations has to do with
how unique their rare earth hypothesis
is
how rare special is earth how rare and
special is the solar system
like if you had to bet all your money on
a
on a completely unscientific question
well no actually it's actually
rigorously scientific we just don't know
a lot of things
in that equation there's a lot of
mysteries about that
and it's slowly becoming better and
better understood in terms of exoplanets
in terms of
how many solar systems are out there
where there's planets they're earth-like
planets that's
getting better and better understood
what's your sense
from that perspective um how many alien
civilizations out there
so zero or one you're right that the
equation
is is being better understood but you're
really only talking about the first
three parameters in the equation or
something you know how many stars are
there how many planets per star
and then we're just barely scratching
the surface of what fraction of those
planets
might be habitable the rest of the terms
in the equation are like how likely is
life to evolve
given habitable conditions how likely is
it to survive all these things
um there are all these huge unknowns
actually i i remember when i first saw
that equation i think i was
i think it was my first year of college
and i thought this is
ridiculous this is a common sense that
didn't need to give a given name
you know um and b just a bunch of
unknowns
it's like putting our ignorance together
in one equation but i've actually
now i understand this equation you know
it's not
something we ever necessarily have the
answer to it's
it just gives us a framework for having
the exact conversation we're having
right now
and i think that's how it was intended
in the first place when it was was put
into writing was to to give people a
language to communicate about
the factors that go into the potential
for aliens to
be out there and for us to find them um
i i would
put money on their being aliens i
would not put money on
us having definitive evidence of them in
my lifetime
well definitive is a funny is a funny
word
because uh my sense is this is the
saddest part
for me is my sense in terms of
intelligent
alien civilizations i feel
like we're so
we're so self-obsessed that we literally
would not be able to detect them
even when they're like in front of us
like like
trees could be aliens but just their
intelligence could be
um realized on a scale
on a time scale or physical scale that
we're not appreciating
like trees could be way more intelligent
than us
i don't know it's just a dumb example
could be rocks rock
or it could be things like
this i love this this is dawkins memes
it could be that
ideas are the like ideas we have
like where do ideas come from where do
thoughts come from maybe
thoughts are the aliens or maybe
thoughts
is the actual mechanisms of
communication
in uh physics right this is like we
think of thoughts as something that
springs
up from neurons firing where the hell do
they come from
and now what about consciousness maybe
consciousness is the communication
it sounds like ridiculous but like
we're so self-centered on this uh
space-time
communication and physical space using
like written language
like spoken with audio
on a time scale that's very specific on
a physical scale it's very specific
uh so so i i tend to think that uh
but bacteria will probably recognize
like like moving organisms will probably
recognize but
when that forms itself into intelligence
most likely be robots of some kind
because we won't be making
the origins we'll be meeting the
creations of those
intelligences we just would not be able
to to appreciate it and that's the
saddest thing to me
that uh we
yeah we when we're too dumb
to see aliens uh like we're too
we kind of think like look at the
progress of science we've accomplished
so much
the sad thing it could be that we're
just like in the first
point zero zero zero one percent of
understanding anything it's humbling
i hope that's true because i feel like
we're very
ignorant as a species and i hope that
our current level of knowledge only
represents the .001 percent of what we
will someday achieve
that actually feels optimistic to me
well that i feel like that's
easier for us to comprehend in the space
of biology
and not as easy to comprehend in the
space of physics for example because we
have a sense that like we have
it like if you if you talk to
theoretical physicists
they have a sense that we understand the
basic laws
that form the nature of reality of our
universe
but it so there's much more comp like
physicists are much more confident
biologists are like uh
this is a squishy mess we're doing our
best uh
physicists but i would be it'd be
fascinating to see if physicists
themselves would also be humble by
their being like what the hell is dark
matter in dark energy
what what the hell is the not just the
origin of the
not just the big bang but uh everything
that happened since the big bang
a lot of things that happened since the
big bang we have no ideas about except
basic models of physics
right or what happened before the big
bang yeah yeah what happened before
or what's happening inside the black
hole why is there a black hole at the
center of our galaxy
can somebody answer this a super massive
black hole
nobody knows how it started and they
seem to be like in the middle of all
galaxies
um so that could be a portal for aliens
to communicate through conscious
okay um all right back to planets
how um what's your favorite outside of
earth what's your favorite planet or
moon
maybe outside of the ones well first
have we talked about it already
or and then if we did mention it what's
the one outside of that
oh gosh i had to come up with another
favorite that's not io
oh iowa's the favorite oh absolutely why
is iowa the favorite
i mean basically everything i've i've
already said it's just such a an
amazing and unique object
but on i guess a personal note it's
probably the object that made me become
a planetary scientist
it's the first thing in the solar system
that really
deeply captured my interest um and
when i started my phd i wanted to be an
astrophysicist working on things like
galaxy evolution
um and sort of slowly i had done some
projects in the solar system but io was
the thing that like really caught me
into doing solar system science
okay let's let's leave uh moons aside
what's your favorite planet it sounds
like you like moons better than planets
so it's uh that's accurate but the
planets are
are fascinating i think you know i find
the planets in the solar system really
fascinating what i
like about the moons is that they
there's so much less that is known
there's still a lot more discovery space
and the questions that we can ask are
still the the bigger questions
gotcha which you know i and maybe i'm
being unfair to the planets because
we're still
trying to understand things like was
there ever life on mars and that is a
huge question and one that
we've sent numerous robots to mars to
try to answer
so maybe i'm being unfair to the planets
but but there is certainly quite a bit
more information
that we have about the planets than the
moons but i mean venus
is is a fascinating object so i like the
objects that
lie at the extremes i think that if we
can make a sort of theory or
like i've been saying framework for
understanding planets and moons that can
incorporate even the most extreme ones
then you know those are the things that
really test your
theory and test your understanding and
so they've always really fascinated me
not so much the nice habitable places
like earth but these extreme places like
venus that have um
sulfuric acid clouds and just incredibly
hot and dense surfaces
and venus of course i i love volcanism
for some reason and venus
has probably has volcanic activity
definitely has in the recent past
maybe has ongoing today
you